davon habe ich schon seit Tagen geträumt
deshalb habe ich mir einfach gemacht
meatball Pasta let's go als erstes
machen wir die Mischung für unsere
Meatballs oder polpette wie man in
Italien sagen würde dafür brauchen wir
rinfleisch Petersilie Semmelbrösel und
ein Ei wenn das Ganze gut durchgeknetet
ist gebe ich noch ein bisschen Parmesan
dazu und dann rolle ich das Ganze
ungefähr so groß wie ein Tischtennis bei
die mietbs sind fertig die Pfanne ist
heiß und wir geben sie hinein jetzt
braten wir die von allen Seiten an und
machen der Zwischenzeit eine Tomatensoße
schaut euch das einfach mal an wie
wunderschön das vor sich hinbrutzelt wir
beginnen mit Olivenöl wir brauchen
einige geschnittene Zwiebel ein wenig
später kommt der Knoblauch dazu dann
können wir auch schon unsere Tomaten
dazu geben die kochen wir jetzt schön
weich als nächstes kochen wir unsere
Nudeln unsere Tomatensoße würzen wir mit
Chili Oregano frischen tyman und
Rosmarin sowie Basilikum duftet wirklich
wunderschön in dieser Küche jetzt gehen
wir unsere knusprigen mietbols rüber in
die Soße und lassen Sie hier fertig
köcheln türm und Rosmarin habe ich
wieder rausgesammelt jetzt müssen wir
nur noch
anrichten